大家好，欢迎收听本期的范莱章和卧师老范。
我是雪梨。
咱们这一期要跟大家聊一聊留学。
终于聊到留学了。
作为两个曾经的流子。
作为兼职做富日留学和生学指导这么多年的我。
范老师。
咱们聊到第14期，终于聊到留学了。
咱也不知道为什么之前这么多期从来没有提到过这个。
有可能对于咱们两个来说，比留学值得分享的事太多了。
有可能是因为留学这一个经历有点年头太久了。
可能对于咱们来说的话是曾经发生过的事。
对。
刚好也借着十月开学季，又有很多的新鲜留子。
成功的入坑了。
这一波韭菜又在着状的成长了。
希望听完我们的节目，你们可以不成为那批被割的韭菜。
有可能已经被割了一批了。
就希望之后可以少割一些吧。
割韭菜这件事从你开始准备出国，就已经某种程度上在发生了。
对，如果不是很幸运的话，甚至你会被一条龙的割下来。
对。
那通过这期节目，我们是希望那些准备来日本留学，
或者对留学这件事还抱有好奇心的朋友们，
能对于日本留学有一个更加接地气的认知。
因为我和雪黎并不是什么大富大贵的家庭，
我们两个就是普普通通公心结层家庭出身的两个孩子。
对，虽然我们一个是北京的，一个是天津的，
但是我们家里面真的没有很有钱。
而对于那些已经在日本留学生活的朋友们呢，
我们也想通过今天我们的分享来帮助大家避一些坑。
那么第一个问题我觉得是很多人最关心的一个问题，
就是留学真的需要很多钱吗？
我觉得这个问题也是大家对留学这件事最常见的一个误区。
而且这个也是现在网上讨论最热烈的一个话题，
觉得不需要很多钱的那批人，
可能是跟欧美比他不需要很多钱。
那那些认为富日留学需要花很多钱的人，
可能是跟在国内上大学比。
对，他可能对留学这件事没有一个概念。
对，那站在我们两个的立场，
一个普通家庭出身的曾经的留学生来讲的话，
日本留学确实需要花一些钱，
但这不是一场烧钱的游戏，
不是说你有钱就万事大吉了，
而是说这是一场关于规划和取舍的一个博弈，
一个考验。
那么首先先说现实，
那么费用确实不低，
你前期要交的报名费呀，
签证呀，机票呀，健康体检呀，
甚至说你交给中介的一些中介费用，
再加上你来之前需要申请日本的房子，
这个时候就涉及到一个海外审查，
那么有海外审查的房子，
一般它的价格会比较高一些，
押金，房租呀，甚至有的房子还有礼金的，
然后你出到日本，
你添的那些家具呀，交通卡呀，
这都是一笔费用。
那么学费方面呢，
我是公立大学出身，
所以呢每年的学费就是。
53万到56万日元左右，
你入学之前一次性交的这个入学金是28万。
那么我呢，是私立大学出身，
我当时是大三的时候过来以。
编入生的身份进的这个学校，
然后当时我们的学校的学费是。
100万一年，
第一年的入学金是大概也是20多万，
这个是学费，
然后除了学费以外呢，
不同地区的其实生活开销也是很大的，
像我是在一个很偏僻的农村，
所以我那个地方不管是房租还是生活开销，
相对来说第一期，房租的话是3到4万，
然后吃东西呀，水电没加一块吧，
一个月10万日元左右的一个开销，
那么雪梨是在大板，
大板其实相对还好吧。
那个时候的大板比现在会好很多，
因为我刚来的时候是住宿舍，
所以前半年的这个宿舍方面的费用比较便宜，
大概是在2万日元一个月，
那么从后半年开始就自己租了房子，
那个时候的房租大概是在4万多一点，
然后加上我平时的一些吃喝呀，
一些生活费加起来，其实跟老房差不多，
一个月大概也是在10万上下，
但是有一个问题就是，
现在日本的物价那可真是，
翻了倍的涨，
不管是房租呀，米面油啊，
甚至交通费都在涨，
Giarao都在涨钱，
Giarao应该好像从明天4月份正式要开始涨价了，
对,
每个里程好像高10块钱，
对，公交车也涨钱，
但是一个好消息是，
我们当时留学的时候，
汇率其实是6.7块了，
所以现在已经是低迫5的一个时代的话，
其实大家的总体的花费人民币来讲，
没有说特别的多，
对,
如果按日元算的话，
大概现在东京一个月的话，
要将近15万左右差不多，
对，我当时的话10万其实就打住了，
现在的话我觉得，
怎么也得准备12到18万不懂吧，
你才能有一个比较富裕的一个，
很舒服的一个留学的生活，
相对于没有这么结局，
就你不需要再勒紧亏要带去过日子了，
对,
但是在东京这个地方，
你要知道，
你的生活费是可以无上限的，
取决于你想在东京这么玩，
对,
我觉得东京是一个包容性很强的城市，
你可以过得很穷，
你可以过得很解解，
你也可以过得很奢靡，
那毕竟是世界套不起的一个非常繁华的城市呢？
我见过一个月花10万日元在东京生活的人，
也见过一个月花23百万在东京生活的人，
所以,
换算成人民币其实跟咱们那一阵差不了太多，
大概一个月都是在六七千块钱左右，
那么一年的话，
光生活费就要花将近七八万人民币，
对，差不多，
对吧,
再加上学费啥的，
大概一年十来万，
花的少的话大概十万就够了，
十万左右吧，
十万是一个基础，
我稍微多一些的话，大概十三到十五，
上不封顶，
对，上不封顶，
十万是一个相对于合理的价格，
只是说对于我们两个这种非常注重，
现在比的人来说，
这是一个比较合理的一个范围，
对,
所以说这个其实对于普通家庭来说的话，
已经不是一个小数目了，
对，是的，
但是,
话又说回来了，
这笔钱并非全靠家里面砸出来的，
因为日本对于国际留学生，
是有很多的奖学金的，
对，就是如果你学习非常好的话，
甚至在你来之前，
可以提前去申请全额奖学金，
对,
你像我们那个学校，
学费是五十多万一年，
但是我们一年可以申请两次的学费减免，
咱不能说百分之百吧，
但是我当初的话，
两年四次我申请中了三次，
你们是要申请然后再审查的这样子的行事吗？
对，对，对，
它不是百分之百过，
但是一定是绝大部分的，
所以我当初其实就是二十多万就上了一年去，
那你这个非常便宜了？
就是一万多块钱，
一万多块钱的话，
其实在国内一个私立的一个大学的话，
民营的一个大学的话也就一万多块钱，
也差不多，
甚至有的三名要比这个还贵，
但是我当时的这个私立大学的话，
针对所有的外国人，
都会有百分之三十的学费减免，
反而日本人是全额，
也就是说日本人需要交一年一百万的学费，
而我们作为外国人只需要交七十万，
然后我们到了硕士的时候，
其实学费就跟老饭的学校差不多了。
这个还是最基本的学费减免，
在此基础之上，
你还可以申请各个财团的，
地方政府的大学的企业的助学金，
讲学金，基本上吧，
如果你就正常上学的话，
每个人都可以申请到一到两个讲学金。
而且每一个学校合作的讲学金的这些财团，
机构非常的多。
而且每一个学校都有教育支援科，
都有专门的老师来帮你去弄这些手续。
对，如果是少了讲学金的话，
一个月大概是两到四万块钱左右。
多的这种讲学金的话，
一个月能拿到大概八万块钱。
现在这个说的是我和雪梨的大学和大学院的。
这么一个学校可以申请到一些很多的讲学金了。
其实现在在语言学校，
你甚至都可以申请一些优良的讲学金，
你找好学习，
虽然它不多吧，
但是至少可以稍微来补充一下生活费，
然后在上学的时候，
你还能申请一些学校的兼职，
兼职价格就非常高了。
一个小时基本上都在两三千左右。
比如说什么申请研究助理啊，
TA啊，RA啊这种岗位。
那这个应该是针对你们这种硕士，
或者是研究性的这样的学校会有的这样的岗位吧？
对，一般大学院都会有，
或者说你到了大四阶段，
不是进到研究室了吗？
每个学校其实都会有TA或者硕士研究助理，
或者RA这种岗位的。
看教授的一个配额，
再加上日本是允许留学生合法打工的，
但是限额是每周28个小时。
对，然后每年的话，
这个打工的这个金额也是有限制的。
它也不是有限制，
它有一个最低减免额度。
就是你每年如果打工超过103万的话，
多余的部分你是需要交税的。
而且在第二年，
不仅你的健康保险会上涨，
还会找你纳税。
所以大家如果要打工的话，
尽量把这个金额控制一下。
像我当时的话，
其实我没有打很多的工，
因为当时学业还挺紧张的，
所以每个月大概平均来讲是8万到10万左右。
差不多，
超时打工还有一个不好的一个点。
我觉得这个，
如果不是你亲身经历过遇到过，
没有人会告诉你呢，
就是在日本有一个高额疗养制度，
对于留学生这种无收入人群来讲的话，
或者低收入人群来讲的话，
它是可以享受到最低33000的一个党的。
什么概念呢？
就是即使住院了，需要做手术，
不管多少钱，
100万、200万、300万、400万、500万也好，
你只需要负担33000这个额度，
那么除此之外，全是国家给你负担。
这个好在不需要你垫付，
你就是在交费的时候，
十九、33000,。
其他的你根本就不需要交，
是医院找国家去要的。
但是,
如果你超额了，
那你这个党就会提一党变成5万多。
对，这就很尴尬了，
你本来就没超多少钱，
你第二年的保险料的上涨，
你补交的税，
再加上你看病多花的这些钱，
把你去年挣的这些钱有可能，
全搭进去了？
还得多，
有点得不尝失了，
这就是资本主义国家不坑穷人。
这其实它保证了，
每一个人都是平等的？
对,
然后我们说回来，
再加上合法打工的这么一个，
这么一个每个月的8万到10万左右吧，
这么一个收入，
基本上能覆盖生活开销的一部分，
再加上家里面支援一点的话，
其实很多同学都是在办公，
办读这种状态下完成学业的。
对,
然后到了假期的时候，
其实你可以多打一点，
假期的时候可以打满5天的，
5天每天8个小时40个小时，
所以按照这样来说的话，
其实每年家庭的负担就可以小，
三分之一到二分之一左右。
如果说你全年的开销是10万人民币的话，
那么你办公办读，
再加上这些基础奖学金吧，
咱就不说那些申请到很高额奖学金了，
咱就说基础奖学金吧，
基本上可以帮你省掉3到5万人民币的开销。
对,
如果是你是读一个私立大学的话，
那么你的家庭可能就只需要负担，
大概不到100万的学费就够了。
那么如果你是像老饭一样，
他读的是一个国立大学的话，
那就更少了，
一年可能也就是个两三万块钱。
对，那家生活的话，
一年家庭负担，
你的父母帮你去出的这些钱，
可能就会从10万降到5万，
甚至更少。
那么这样的话，
你就发现好像很多家庭都能负担得起了。
对，这样的话，
其实留学这件事就不是一件咬不可及的事儿。
对，在按5万来说的话，
一年5万人民币的话，
那么折合一个月的话，
就是4000出头吧。
那么4000出头这么一个数的话，
我觉得大部分双职工家庭都可以做到，
它不是一件很困难的事儿。
所以钱其实不是最关键的问题。
那么除了钱以外，
可能取舍和规划，
可能是一个比较重要的一个方面。
就比如说东京的生活贵，
但是郊区的房租会相对便宜一点。
你房租就可以省一部分。
那如果你可以跟同学合足的话，
又可以省掉一半。
那么自己做饭呢？
那在饮食上就可以再省出来一笔钱。
然后你的家店也好，
还是你的家具也好，
你去收一些学长学姐的呀，
小红书出的二手的呀，
然后你出行的时候，
因为你上学的话可以买学生的定期券。
所以呢，你只要在定期券，
覆盖范围之内的车站上下是不花钱的。
那你是不是可以在出行的时候，
规划线路的时候，
可以尽量的往你定期券的路线上靠。
这样的话你出行也可以省一些钱。
所以与其说留学需要很多钱，
倒不如说他需要算账的能力，
就是你得懂得预期懂得支配，
懂得怎么样在保证自己生活质量的情况下去省钱。
就是还是要追求一个极致的性价比，
就是如果你是一个公心结层，
但是你拿着父母给的钱，
在日本去大手大脚的花的话，
这样就不太合理了。
我觉得这个也是东京不好的一个点，
就是东京这种过于包容的环境，
就是上线和下线的差距过于大的时候，
就会容易让人迷失在这个繁华的都市当中。
就是你本来没有那么多钱，
但是你身边有有钱的人，
然后你就会觉得，
我也有钱，
我也去花这么多钱，
去体验那样的一个生活，
就迷失在这个花花世界当中。
那么这个也是钱带给人的另一种教育。
就是你作为一个普通家庭，
你作为一个公心结层出身的一个人，
那么你就要学会自我管理，
你就要开始记录你的每一笔支出，
你就要懂得取舍，懂得权衡，直还是不直。
雪梨就有一个特别好的习惯，
它的每一笔钱，
它都会详细的记录下来，
然后去总结每一个月，
每一年的一个开销，
然后连续记录几年，
看一下最近几年的一个消费的一个变化的一个情况。
那么相对来说，
我做这点做的就比较差，
我只是有一个笼统的一个概念。
我对于钱没有什么概念，
是因为我本身的钱没有什么欲望，
我花钱没有什么欲望，
对于挣钱没有什么欲望。
有的用就完事了。
对对对，能够饭吃就行。
所以说留学刚开始的时候，
可能需要集中的花掉家里的一笔钱，
但是你收获的可能就不只是文凭了，
你还是对资源、欲望以及生活节奏。
或者金钱管理的一个重新的一个利息。
我觉得这种自我管理，
光是在留学阶段的一个学习。
就是你学会了这项技能之后，
它也是为你之后，
不如社会做的一个很好的一个基础和准备。
对，像雪梨这个习惯，
就是从上学那儿保持过来的，
因为我没有一个良好的一个习惯。
所以以至于我工作了前两年，
我甚至都不知道我的钱是怎么没的。
反正就没了。
我就知道我没了那个钱。
那就在这。
对,
然后反而是跟雪梨在一块以后，
我开始学着记证了。
当我回看的时候，
我才知道，
原来这个月在这花了一笔钱，
原来今年马里格这个花了一个大笔钱。
我才对于这个开销有概念。
所以我们话说回来，
留学真的需要很多钱吗？
我觉得答案是要，
一定需要一笔钱。
在你开始准备留学的时候，
这笔钱是你出来的勇气，
是你出来的底气。
但这个数额，
是普通公心阶层也可以负担的一个数额。
那么钱，
它是门票，
它不决定你能不能走下去。
其实真正决定你能不能留学的，
我觉得是准备的一个心态，
或者你的规划能力，
以及你在现实里维持生活的一个勇气，
因为你出来的以后是完全要靠自己的。
你的父母有点边长莫及，
他们有劲使不出的那种感觉，
他们想要关心你，
想要帮你分担，
但是他们不知道该如何去帮你分担。
所以很多事就是要靠你自己来往前走。
那这就是今天要聊的第一个问题。
那第二个问题就是，
是不是在日本日语好就万事大吉了？
因为有很多人觉得，
我只要拿到了N1，
我就能在日本如鱼得水。
那考到N1之后就天下无敌了？
对对对，
但实际上，
其实根本不是这么回事。
这就是一种典型的语言版能论，
语言考试的成绩，
只是来日本的一个入场卷。
哪怕你考到N1，
它只能说明你在应识教育上面的一个成功，
并不代表你可以有开口说话的能力，
它甚至有时候都听不懂。
对,
它考得有点纸面知识。
但是生活中的日语，
其实是通过社会经验来积攒的，
什么课堂呀，职场呀，
超市啊，医院啊，
在这种不同的环境下，
你用的语言是完全不一样的。
所以当我开始在日本留学了以后，
我会发现，
我在学生时代学过最有用的日语，
是商务日语，
就是当时我们商务日语是一门课，
这门课程里面交了。
在日本的不同的场景下，
使用的这些社会的语言和商务的语言，
反而会比课本上的这些。
书面上的语言会更有效，
更直接。
再加上，
日本有什么房言呀，
口语呀，省略语呀，
甚至还有语气差异。
对，而且那个时候我还是在大板留学，
所以天天听他们讲大板话。
对，对，对。
所以即使你有N1，
也会经常在
绘画中卡住。
对，甚至你在这边留学几年以后，
这种情况可能才会慢慢的卡住环节。
对。
就比如说日本人喜欢用那种。
围弯起模糊的表达方式。
对，这是日语的一个非常明显的特征。
对，爱内语，对对对。
他从来不会很明显很直白地告诉你，
他到底想表达什么东西。
对对对。
或者你跟他说，
我们一起去哪儿呢？那儿玩吧。
他说好，这个地方真有意思。
下次一块去吧，
或者有时间一块去吧。
他就是在拒绝你。
他就不想跟你去。
对，那么如果你听不出。
这种微妙的这个语感，
哪怕你的日语再流离，
在这个社交生活上也会到处碰壁的。
其实总结来说，日语就是一个敲门砖。
你有了N1，有了N2，
只能证明你有了尝试。
日本生活在日本求学的资格。
但不代表你的日语就好了。
往往N1只是一个开端。
你有了N1，
其实你日语的学习才刚刚开始。
对的。
你要去理解语言背后，
那些语法，那些文字背后。
想表达的意思。
如果你人在国内的话，
你有了N1，
可能能证明你在日语方面。
有一定的进步，有一定的成就，
你比别人可能会有一个优势，
但是这种优势来到日本之后，
你就会变得跟大家一样了。
就像一个老外，
他中文学的嘎嘎六，
代表他很厉害吗？
不是,
他只代表他能跟你平等的交流。
甚至他问你什么意思，
你跟他说意思意思，
他都不知道你表达的是什么意思。
所以说，
这种意思意思的意思，
就需要你靠生活经验的积累来去理解。
这个至于日语也是一样的一个概念。
那么第三个问题，
专门学校真的比大学要低级吗？
在中国这个环境里面，
学历其实是被严重神话的。
对,
大家每个人其实都带着一种。
学历比识链在看这个问题。
对,
很多人听到专门学校这个词，
就马上想到了大专，
直高,
次等教育，
类伴这些词。
就恨不得你从这些学校出来之后，
你只能去跑滴滴，
送外卖，
做一些服务行业，
没容美发。
确实是这样，
好像,
你从专门学校出来，
可不就是去，
没容美发。
当初是，
你可不就干点什么呀？
只能是说，
社会的这个，
定位不一样。
理解没有问题，
但是,
但是在日本，
专门学校，
其实它是一个独立的一个体系的，
它是和大学，
并行的一种教育路线，
而不是向国内的大学的退路，
叫做大专。
不管在社会地位上，
还是在认知层面，
它都是一个平等的一个概念。
就可能，
专门学校更注重于，
使用教育。
对,
它更强调于，
务实技能。
而大学，
或者说大学院更注重的是，
学术的教育，
或者是学术上的研究，
对,
日本最牛逼的动画专业师，
专门学校，
而且他们除了有成熟的，
课程体系之外，
他们还有很成熟的，
资格认证的一个路径。
就比如说，
相比于大学四年的一个理论训练，
专门学校更加的有一点，
工作导向，
就是技能导向，
这么一个概念。
而且很多日本的公司，
在招聘的时候，
喜欢这种专门学校的学生，
就比如说，
我一个同事，
他是专门学校毕业的，
他会被人高看一等。
那肯定的。
就是，在他们的概念里面，
你是专门学校出来的，
你代表了啥呢？
你代表了一个极战力。
你的专业技能是过硬的。
对，你来了，
就可以干活。
你像我们，
本科碩士毕业了以后，
进去是要经过培训的。
教你怎么干活，
他们会按照一张白纸，
来训练你，来教给你。
但是专门学校不一样，
专门学校你毕业了，
到了职场，
他们就会认为，
你是带着专业技能来的，
你就是一个经验者，
你就是一个，
可以立马作为，
战力投入到实际的，
工作当中的一个人。
对，这样的人，
反而在这种情况下，
会比我们是文科大学院出身的人，
来说,
找工作会更有优势。
对,
还有一个就是，
日本很奇怪的一个，
现象,
学历越高，
反而你的就业面越窄。
这是最恐怖的。
你感兴吧，
一个博士出来找不着工作，
但是一个大专生，
出来满大街的工作。
他们会考虑，
就是你是一个博士，
你已经在这个专业，
深耕了这么多年了，
你一定要找一个，
相关专业，
相关领域的一个工作，
那么很好，
你的就业面，
就被局限于你的专业了，
所死了。
反而是那些低血力的人，
你到了任何一个公司，
都是一张白纸，
那么很幸运的是，
日本公司就喜欢培养白纸，
他们喜欢从零去教人。
所以其实在日本，
如果要找工作的话，
你没必要说，
追求一个过高的一个血力，
这个就牵扯出来了，
你来日本的目的是什么？
对,
如果你是想来度个金，
说白了，
我毕业以后，
我就要回国，
那请一定要上一个。
名气大的学校，
那如果你来留学，
是为了，
搞学术，
搞研究，
你真的是热爱你的专业的话，
其实,
更推荐一些，
研究型的一些院校，
就是在你的专业领域很强，
但是,
这个学校可能没有什么名气。
那么如果你来日本，
留学之后的目的是，
为了要工作的话，
那这就又不一样了。
那就要看你，
自己想干什么，
我觉得，
如果想干一些，
实用技能项的，
那读一个专门学校，
也未尝不可。
或者说，
你一定想要追求一个血力的话，
其实考一个大学，
大四毕业了之后，
直接去找工作，
其实就够了。
也可以，
但是,
你不要把说，
你对大学四年，
想学什么专业技能，
更多的是，
这四年努力的，
融入日本社会。
对,
然后增加了一个，
学生时代的一个体验吧。
对,
所以最后一句话总结吧，
在日本，
可能,
血力没有高低贵贱之分，
只是人生选择的方向不同，
然后,
然后以上就是对于，
即将来日本，
或者对日本留学，
抱有好奇的朋友们，
他们可能集中会有的一些问题。
那么接下来，
我们就来聊一聊，
已经在日本的，
那些留学生们，
那些朋友们，
容易走入的一些物区，
或者容易踩的一些坑。
我觉得，
想留在日本，
工作的那些留子，
都特别容易陷入到的一个物区，
他们会对，
就业有一个过高的一个期待。
这个物区，
其实在我该是，
找工作的时候也是有的，
对吧,
毕业以后，
留在日本工作很容易的，
日本这么缺人，
日本在招聘会上，
都是跪下来，
求着人家入职的，
所以你留在日本，
找一个工作是非常容易的。
其实说难嘛，
也不是特别难，
说简单也没有那么简单，
就是从现实的层面去看的话，
日本的就业市场，
对于留学生来讲，
并不是，
特别的友好。
短,
而且越来越不友好。
对,
方方面面都有一种，
收紧的趋势，
尤其是像我这种，
文科大学院出身的女生，
现在日本企业，
招收国际留学生的比率，
大约是35%，
再加上现在，
所谓的国际局势，
相对来说比较紧张，
所以很多传统的日期，
对于采用留学生，
是非常谨慎的，
尤其是中国留学生，
对,
尤其是一些日本的中小企业，
或者说华人的一些中小企业，
对,
他们的幼稚人会更加的谨慎，
那么大企业的话，
虽然有这样的名额，
但是,
这些名额可能会在陆续减少，
就很多留学生毕业以后，
找不到对口的工作，
然后他被迫转，
做了非专业的岗位，
有很多很多很多，
还有一个过高的期待，
就在于理想化的日本职场，
之前经常会听到的，
什么日本社会有秩序，
企业稳定，
进去就是终身互勇制，
这个稳定的另一面，
带来的其实是，
等级制度特别森严，
而且他们的晋升，
真的就是纯靠年头，
甚至那些大公司，
涨工资都是几千日元，
几千日元的涨，
一年一两百，
对对对，都是这种概念的，
人民币就约等于没涨，
连通过膨胀都跑不赢，
对，所以有很多人在这种大手企业，
做了很多年之后，
才会想说要赚更多的钱，
然后再去跳槽到一些小公司，
对，所以你想赚钱，
就不要其他公司，
在日本也是一个非常，
反直觉的一个现象，
所以就是，
如果你想去一个日期，
那么你就要提前做准备，
语言呀，资格真人啊，
时期经历呀，交流能力，
你都要提前的去训练，
去天的去准备，
那么你觉得自己不是一个能够。
接受这种日期的相对于，
紧绷的，
相对于森严的一种职场文化的话，
那你就可以把目标放在外资上，
因为现在日本的外资，
也非常的流行，非常的盛行，
甚至有很多日期在外资化，
有很多年轻的日期在外资化，
比如说佩佩，
它就是一个典型的日期，
然后外资化的一个日期，
比如说，
有一个咨询公司叫做Future，
还有很多日本的创业型公司，
他们都是典型的在外资化，
那么这种企业对于外国人，
是比较友好的，
而且他们的职场环境，
相对来说轻松一些，
自由一些，
但是有一个很严重的问题，
就是,
这种企业一般对英语的要求非常高，
他想说，
所以打算在日本找工作的朋友们，
一定不要想说，
我已经在日本找工作了，
那么英语就可以丢掉了，
并不是的，
其实在日本，
你的英语越好，
在某种方面来说，
你就会更有优势，
尤其是这些，
学校或者说是企业，
可能会更看重拖业，
对，拖业更讲究一个，
实用性，
对,
所以如果有能力的朋友们的话，
尽量可以往高考，
拖业是990万分，
你能考到800以上，
基本上你就可以平汤了，
对,
不管你是考学也好，
还是工作也好，
你的拖业能考到800分以上，
你基本上就在日本横着走，
因为日本人的英语很烂很烂，
所以说，
如果想要注重一个性价比来讲的话，
拖业是比较好学，
然后能获得高分的这么一个考试，
对,
好巧的就是啥呢，
大学不是考过四六级吗？
考完四六级，
马上考拖业，
一般都会考得比较高，
如果是考完六级的朋友们的话，
拖业怎么也能考高，
600多，700左右，
你不准备，
直接考的那种可能就700，
再稍微准备准备的话，
过800,
但是到900以上，
都不是很难的一件事，
所以相对来讲，
其实拖幅的必要性就没有这么大了，
拖幅亚斯，
其实反而不是很重要，
那如果你的英语也不行，
你又不想去那种传统的日期，
去接受压迫，
接受打压，
那你可以去华人企业吗？
但是华人企业其实就是，
坑会比较多嘛，
所以这个时候，
就需要你去擦两双眼，
然后仔细去甄别一下。
对,
这就是说到我们下一个想，
跟大家聊的，
在国外一定要警惕，
你不认识的华人同胞。
对,
我觉得这一点，
可能不光是日本吧，
就是任何一个国外的一个国家，
都要首先警惕你的同胞。
对,
你只要出了国门，
对于那种不认识的中国人，
过来给你献殷勤的，
你要留个心眼儿。
你要留个心眼儿，
对,
这句话听起来很刺耳，
但是听这题节目的，
在日本生活的人都懂，
同胞不等于可信，
就是那些诈骗，
非法兼职，
那些租房坑人，
代购骗子，
假中介，
几乎都是中国人干的。
包括现在为什么，
各行各业，
包括学生，
金银管理签，
这种东西，
都在各方面在收紧，
某种程度上，
就是因为之前的中国人，
做的这些事情。
对,
这叫,
钱人砍树，
后人爆晒。
我们某种程度上，
就为爆晒来很多词。
对,
常见在日本，
这边的华人片局，
有一些，
比如说，
我帮你找房，
我有内部名额，
然后拿了钱消失的，
用那种高薪兼职，
帮忙送货的，
一般都是一些灰产。
还有就是那种，
你帮我带点东西回国，
你回国嘛，
你给我带个东西回国，
或者你给我带个东西过来，
让结果牵扯到一些伪进品。
对,
所以第一个享受的注意点，
就是不要随便给，
自己的一些信用信息，
和个人信息，
然后不要帮别人去买东西，
不要随便点一些链接，
有可能遇到杀猪盘。
对,
就是这类陷阱，
一般都是利用那种，
来日本的这种留学生，
日语又不是特别好，
然后对于这个环境，
不是特别熟悉，
可能对于，
会讲中文的人，
天生有一种依赖，
或者有一种信任感。
对,
然后结果，
你就是那个韭菜，
对,
你就被你的铜包坑了，
就是在国外，
有一句话叫，
中国人只坑中国人，
或者坑中文的，
一定是中国人。
所以,
话说回来，
调侃归调侃，
我们在国外，
还是要多查证，
少冲动，
所有的钱，
所有的手续，
都要走正规合法的，
账户合同，
那么学校也好，
中介也好，
公司也好，
一定要能从网上，
查到那种注册号的，
然后也不要轻易的，
交现金，
也不要轻易的，
跟学生，
跟不认识的人，
私下换会，
换钱,
那么更不要把，
护照和在留卡，
借给别人，
这种问题，
不要再出现了，
因为我们见过，
很多留学生，
把护照和在留卡，
借给别人，
然后人家做一些，
违法的一些事，
导致自己，
在日本的信用度归零。
这个时候，
就会送你一张，
遣返的机票，
甚至有的人，
可能会面与，
老与之在。
对,
如果你遇到了一些，
你觉得，
可能会有问题的事，
请第一时间，
找到你的，
老师,
或者警察，
千万不要怕麻烦，
即使你说不明白，
不要你报了警，
警察会努力的明白，
你想表达啥，
因为他们的前提，
是保证你的安全。
当然,
这个世界还是好人多的，
就是,
心存善意的同胞，
一定是占绝大部分的。
像咱们上一期，
聊的那个早餐店，
来带一大妈，
他们就是很善良的中国人。
那么除了这些，
骗局以外，
还有很多坑，
严格的说，
他不是在骗你，
他只是通过你，
挣到了更多的钱，
就比如说，
刚来日本，
你不知道电话卡怎么办吧？
好,
现在有人过来说，
哎,
朋友,
来,
我帮你办一个电话卡，
多少钱多少钱多少钱，
你看,
在我这儿办便宜，
你去音乐厅办是这个价，
好,
他说的没问题，
他给你看那个价格，
也肯定是音乐厅的价格，
但是这不代表你省钱了，
是因为在日本，
有很多很多的隔安卡，
有很多很多的活动，
甚至,
我和雪梨，
我们两个去转设的时候，
人事都会给反现金的，
我刚来的时候，
就踩了这个坑，
我在刚来日本，
第一周的时候，
就遇到一个非常好心的一个同胞，
然后他打着帮，
留月生去，
办这些业务的旗号，
去给我们，
每一个人都办了，
5000块钱,
日元,
一个月的合约机，
当时好像还没有流行说，
隔安卡这种东西，
所以那个5000日元的合约机，
其实是强制性的，
后来过了几月之后，
才发现，
它其实在我们每个人身上，
都可以赚好几万的一个反点的，
然后中介完全没有跟我们说这件事，
他自己全都把这个钱给密了，
然后最过分的是，
这个合约机，
其实它也是有解约金的，
就是你可能，
不到两年，
你需要交，
一个月还是多少钱的一个解约金，
是包含在这个合同范围之内的，
但是它当时，
也并没有跟我们做一个系统的讲解，
就导致我们在想，
鞋号转网的时候，
才发现，
可能要交一两万的解约金，
像类似的情况，
还需要警惕，
各种各样的中介，
什么房屋中介，
就职中介，
什么留学中介，
甚至有一些行政舒适，
就是怎么说呢，
能找日本人，
就找日本人，
或者你实在觉得，
这个人非常靠谱的话，
你可以找他去办理这个业务，
当有人给你推销，
某一些产品，
某一些东西的时候，
你可以拿着，
去跟市面上的同类型产品，
做一个对比，
看一下他是否真的，
给你了一些，
相对实惠的优惠，
比如说，
刚才说的这个租房的中介，
租房中介，
其实他是可以两头赚钱的，
有的时候，
他给你推一些，
比较好的一些房子，
其实他可以从房东那儿，
首先收到一个月房租，
或者两个月房租的，
广告费，
然后他管你要一个月的，
中介费，
所以其实很多的中介，
如果他好心的话，
他是可以，
不像你收这笔中介费的，
对，他如果跟你说，
咱们俩这关系，
我就不收你中介费了，
那他一定是有广告费，
可以收的，
如果说，
中介费给你便宜点儿，
给你0.5个月吧，
这只代表，
他赚了你0.5月的中介费，
但是,
这不代表，
他只赚了你0.5月的中介费，
有可能他那边广告费，
赚了两个月的，
所以其实你也没必要对他，
一定要感恩戴德，
怎么怎么样的，
就是他做这件事儿，
如果他跟你的关系一般的话，
一定是带着某一种目的的，
没有人是做慈善的，
无力不齐早，
就是他过来帮你找房子，
帮你租房子，
他是一定有利可图的，
然后租房方面，
还有一个可能会踩的坑，
就是押金在退房的时候，
可能不一定能全额退回，
这个的话就不光是说华人了，
很多讨厌的日本人的中介，
或者日本人的管理公司，
也会有这个问题，
对,
所以租房首先就是在。
租房的入住的时候，
要记得拍照，
就房屋里面有瑕疵，
有屋子的地方，
首先要记得先拍照，
然后签约的时候，
要看清合同里面到底写的是，
几年解约，
才没有违约金，
那么都看清楚了之后，
在到时候你退房的时候，
你才可能会被全额退回这笔押金。
一般向正规的公司，
或者说是比较讲理的公司，
你在入住之前都会给你两份材料，
一份材料是照片，
打印出来A4纸大小的，
一张一张的照片，
然后里面明确的有，
这件房屋哪里有瑕疵，
他们发现的，
既存的一些瑕疵，
他还会给你一个确认表，
你入住了一个月之内，
你可以看到这个房屋里面有瑕疵，
你可以记录在这个表上，
然后寄给他们，
这都可以作为你退房时候的一个证据，
然后在你签合约之前，
会有一个宅建式，
不管是当面也好，
还是在网上也好，
他都会向你出示他的证件，
然后跟你讲这个房屋的一些要求，
包括,
但不限于你这个房屋是什么材质的，
哪年见的，
能不能养宠物，
有什么注意事件，
甚至你几年解约，
需要承担多少房屋的损耗费用，
他都会给你写的非常清楚，
讲的非常清楚，
那么如果没有这些流程，
你就要仔细的看清楚你的合约上，
著名的东西了，
你就要小心了，
他有可能会在某些地方给你下套，
在你解约的时候，
会依据那些你当时没有注意到的条款，
来向你索要更多的费用。
还有一点就是，
如果大家需要解约的时候，
在退房的当天，
一定要自己亲自到房子里面，
去跟管理公司退房。
就哪怕你把房子到时候收拾得很干净，
他也可能会以你清扫不到位为理由，
去扣你这一笔押金作为他的清洁费。
但是你要注意，
你在租房子的时候，
你这笔清洁费已经交过了。
对。
所以你在租房子的时候，
你所交的钱里面的每一笔明信，
你都要记清楚。
所以到时候，
如果很不幸，
你被管理公司要求不能返还这笔清洁费的话，
那你到时候的态度一定要强硬一点，
因为这笔钱，
是很有可能会给你全额返回来的。
现在有很多那种比较坏的日本人，
他们抓住了留学生，
这种不懂这些日本的这些法律要求，
他钻这个空子来无甲虎威的找你，
扣这些钱。
对,
所以就是你态度强硬一点的话，
他们可能就会气然怕硬。
对。
如果真的很不幸，
遇到了这样的事情的话，
也不要怕。
其实可以向这个消费者的生活中心，
进行投诉。
日本这边的法律也好，
政府也好，
还是相对于偏向租户的。
对。
这个还是跟国内不太一样的一个状态。
那这就是租房方面，
可能会踩到一些坑。
那还有一个就是，
私熟的坑。
私熟这个坑呢，
其实我跟老饭两个人，
我们都是不约而同地踩过。
我当时在考学的时候呢，
为了想考大学院，
然后觉得说，
一个大板很有名的一个私熟会，
对我的进学很有帮助。
所以我当时选择了一个。
三十多人的大课，
然后交了三十多万。
报这个课之前呢，
那位销售那个老师就跟我说，
随时对我各种的答疑，
然后包括我自己写的研究教书的辅导，
他们会全程更近，
会有班主任。
当时想样确实很美好，
结果上了之后发现，
其实就是给了两本教材，
去跟着这些人一起上大课，
然后,
周中的时候，
会有一些日语和英语的辅导课。
整体的体验下来，
我就觉得整个的课程非常的松散，
老师其实也没有像他之前说的那样的负责。
然后研究教书呢，
其实他就是，
给我从网上翻译翻译，
改一改。
那些修改的老师，
其实也就是一些学校的大学生而已。
甚至有的老师，
他的态度还不一定很好，
他对我经常爱搭不理。
然后当我想去退课的时候，
他跟我说，
这个东西爆了就不能退，
所以就最后导致我这个。
三十几万全都大水漂了。
你并没有得到相应的一个价值，
这个也是，
大家要注意的一个点，
但是这个很难避免，
就是来日本考学的话，
尤其是你要考大学，
或者说是你要考一个很有名的大学院，
你绕不开的就是上私熟，
那么在一众私熟里面，
那可能你更会信任一些大私熟，
但是往往是这些大私熟，
会有像刚才雪梨分享的这种坑，
就是收钱不办事，
或者你收了很多的钱，
但是没有得到相应的价值。
对，因为其实他们很大的一笔钱都花在了营销方面，
而不是注重在进学的专业度上面。
那么我之前跟私熟合作去上课的时候，
那么私熟向学生推销我的课的时候，
它的价格是一万人员一个小时，
然后二十个小时打包起卖，
但是私熟给到我的价格是四千一个小时，
那么在中间私熟什么都没做，
它就挣了绝大部分的钱，
甚至那个私熟对于那个学生的学期效果和成绩，
他们都是不负责的，
甚至他们跟我说你只要上好课就行了，
至于他考不考得上，那咱就不管了。
就是完全就是收钱不办事？
对，然后那个学生也是比较信任我，
因为二十个小时完全不足以支撑他考上这个大学，
所以出来了以后，他就想说，
我能不能单独跟你上课，不通过中级？
拒绝中间商占差价。
对，这样的话，我们绕过了中级，
私下里达成了一个协议，
就是我辅导他直到进入大学院，
然后我一次性地收取一笔费用，
那么他没有拿到路据通知书，
我是收不到这个费用的，
而且他花的钱相比于当初上私熟少了至少百分之六七十，
那这还是在我多证的情况下，
可见日本这边的私熟很大一部分都是相当坑人的。
所以这个就说明了一件事，
在日本如果你想要进学的话，
这样的私熟一定不是必须的，
因为其实你在考学的过程当中，
有一些比如说联系教授啊，
去看他们的过去问的考题啊，
然后去官网收集信息啊，
这些东西其实都是你自己可以去完成的。
这就说到了我们最开始提到了一个信息，
获取和筛选的能力。
对，这个也是后来我做留学资询的时候，
喜欢跟家长或者跟学生来讲的这个点，
就是如果说学生的能力很强，
我一般不建议他去找私熟，
甚至我都不建议他去找语言学校，
因为有很多海外之身的渠道，
有很多获取复习资料的一个途径，
他完全可以靠着自己DIY去完成一个生学，
可以省特别大一笔钱。
但很多学生可能就觉得说，
DIY这件事对我来说太难了，
我并不是一个有执行力或者说自知力的这么一个人，
所以他会把这件事委托给私熟，
或者说是留学中介。
这样就造成了他们在中间拿钱不办事这个问题，
因为私熟这个市场还是相对于比较混乱的，
他没有一个明确的市场规范，
所以导致这个环境鱼龙混杂，
有那种特别厉害的老实自己在做的，
也有那种特别大的中介受现不办事，
那么遇到这种情况可能就更需要你去看一下，
或者听一下你的学长学姐们推荐的那些私熟，
他们会给一个相对于真实的一个评价。
或是与其说是找一个专业的私熟，
不如说是找一个专业课的一个专业的老师会更重要一些。
对，但是我是觉得私熟这个东西吧，
能不花就不花。
对，因为这完全是一笔没有必要的钱。
因为考大学，应该还好，
考大学院的话，
我觉得你的私熟完全就是让你自己再偷懒，
因为大学院讲究的是一个学习方法，
你在私熟，老师们上课更多的是为了应试帮你去考上某一个学校，
但是你即使靠着这个私熟考上了，
那么你进入到这个学校以后，
继续学习也是一个很大的障碍，
因为你发现你并不能跟上这个学校的节奏。
对，所以就是入门可能会简单，
但是毕业的时候还是要靠你自己的能力。
对，这也是为什么我做了这么多年，
我并不希望来日本的学生们去报私熟的一个原因吧。
划分两头啊，
当然你想补一些基础知识，
我觉得还是非常有必要的。
如果参加比如EGU，
或者说是一些专业课考试，
你去上一些私熟去补一些专业知识，
我觉得是非常有必要的。
但是真的是为了生学那种，
所谓的一对一的这种生学私熟的话，
我是觉得没有什么太大的必要。
或者说能不上就尽量不上。
虽然我自己就是干这个，
那么除了这些以外，
还有一个特别严重的一个问题，
也是近两年吧，
从疫情以后越来越多的一个问题，
就是留学生的一个心理问题。
我觉得在以前也有，
但是没有这么的明显。
经历疫情这几年，
我发现不管是身边也好，
还是我听到看到的也好，
存在心理问题的留学生越来越多了。
他们可能刚来日本的时候，
经历这种语言生活身份的这种冲击，
因为疫情那几年，
可能回国不是很方便，
然后所有的课程都转到了一个线上课程，
那么你长期的孤独感带来的这种，
压抑的一个情绪，
一个负面的一个情绪，
那么这些情绪都是难以在朋友圈里，
去被理解或去消解掉的，
于是就引发了很多的一些心理问题。
对，因为很多人可能会觉得，
我来了几个月之后发现，
跟我之前满环冲击的时候，
那个预期不一样，或者说落差非常大，
那么他可能就接受不了这个现实，
所以就慢慢的变得孤独或者说焦虑，
每天就可能活得很疲惫，
其实我觉得这个是每一个留字，
或者说每一个刚来日本的人，
在半年或者一年的时候，
都会遇到的一个，
文化适应的一个过程的一个自然的阶段，
但这并不表明说你是一个失败的，
所以你需要去给这些情绪去找一个宣泄的出口。
日本后省劳动省在2024年的一个调查显示，
近四成的留学生，
都曾出现了不同程度的焦虑，
失眠和情绪低落。
那么就像刚才雪梨说的，
那么这些问题不在于，
你的可能力不够，
不在于你在一国生活的消耗太大了。
那他说的孤独感比较，
然后来自社会的焦虑，
然后可能还有经济压力的一个叠加，
就很容易让人陷入到一种无形的抑郁当中。
对，我遇到的比较严重的情况就是，
我有一位同学他得了中度的抑郁，
然后那天他就吃了安眠药，
我第一次坐救护车就是为了救他，
包括他当时除了学业上面的压力以外，
他的情感方面也受到了很多的阻碍。
所以这个就是一个比较极端的一个情况。
现在学校一般都会有心理资源室，
然后针对不同国家的留学生，
他们也会有相应的语言的咨询，
然后也会有一些社区中心，
甚至说华安的转折组织也有一些热线，
从网上都可以查，
然后如果你们遇到了一些心理问题，
需要排解，需要找人去输解这些心情的话，
我觉得你们可以及时的去找这些组织，
去寻求一个帮助。
对，或者说有的时候你的情况没有到这么严重的阶段，
你只是想找一个宣泄的出口，
那其实我觉得在日本现在来讲，
你去跟一些朋友去出去玩，
或者说是找一些同学啊，
前辈啊去倾诉啊都是可以的，
因为现在小红说上也有很多的社团活动，
对对对，有些社交活动，
对，还有一些组织去徒步的啊，
滑雪的呀，甚至说一块出去吃饭的，
对，其实你可以去培养一些你的个人爱好，
保持一定程度的社交运动，
做戏要规律，
及时的和家人朋友保持一个沟通，
其实都是舒缓自己情绪的一部分，
而且你要允许自己在某一段时间没有状态，
对，就是允许自己脆弱，
对，千万不要把自己逼得太紧，
就是这个喜而逼紧了时间长了是会崩掉的，
人又不是机器，机器还有一个进属疲劳在了对不对，
人一定会有状态好的状态不好的时候，
所以你要给自己的情绪就有一个容错的一个空间，
总结来说吧，就是在国外作为一个留学生，
那么照顾好自己的情绪其实也是一门必修课，
那我们说了这么多问题，这么多坑，
那就有人问了，问了，
那你们为什么还要留学呀，
尤其是疫情过后的这两年，
关于留学关于润的话题太多了，
而且好像每个人都有资格去评判，
有人说浪费钱也好，
有人说你镀金也好，
还有人说你是逃避现实也好，
你在国内祸没下去你才出的窝，
但是对真正经历过的人来说，
留学它不是逃也不是一种光环，
就是一次被迫的成长，
不管你是被国内的现实逼迫的走投无路的来日本，
还是被日本的现实逼迫的，
它都是你自身的一次成长。
对，所以我觉得来日本留学不是逃离原来的生活，
而是去体验一种未知的新鲜的一个生活方式。
这个时候你会学会自立，学会资源管理，
时间管理，你也会学会去日本人，
或者说日本人的朋友去沟通，
这些经验都会是你宝贵的财富。
所以其实留学不是完全为了来学知识的，
那么钱也好，语言也好，学校也好，
工作也好，签证也好，还是你自己的心理也好，
你会发现每一个问题它都不是知识，
而是实实在在的生活。
那么在生活这个问题上，
其实每一个人的答案都不一样，
所以说每一个人的留学的经历，
每一个人留学的体验都是不一样，
我们见过那种晚上提着垃圾袋，
边走边喘的那种留学生，
半夜打工回来的，
也有那种天天吃喝玩乐，
只醉金迷的留学生，
也有那些来了两三个月坚持不下去回国的留学生，
那么也有那种一边努力学习，
一边努力打工，
养活自己的那种非常努力向上的留学生，
留学只是一个机会，
或者说只是一个过程，
你在这个过程中变成了一个什么样的人，
你在那个过程当中收获了一些什么，
才是留学真正的价值，
所以咱们现在聊到这，
再回头看就会发现，
咱们今天聊的那些关于钱也好，
语言也好，学校也好，
工作也好，同胞也好，
甚至是心理，
它其实都在指向同一个答案，
我们来留学是去学习一种新的生活方式，
或者说去塑造自己新的人生的，
所以与其说，
我跟雪梨留学的那几年，
读的是书，倒不如说，
我跟雪梨之前的那几年，
读的是生活，
让我们学会了如何与自己相处，
让我们学会了如何在一国他乡去照顾好自己，
所以这个可能就是，
我们对于留学的一个答案吧，
那听到这，
如果你们也有像我们一样类似的留学经历，
或者说对于留学有一些问题，
有一些好奇的，
也可以在评论区里面跟我们分享，
或者加挺偶群，
来群里面，
跟大家一起分享，
那么我们也会之无不言，
言无不尽，
为大家解答关于日本，
关于留学的一些问题，
好吧,
那以上就是本期节目的全部内容了，
这里是翻来张口，我是大范，
我是雪梨，
我们下期再见，
拜拜!